ja der titel stimmt ich habe mir den
vermutlich größten meiner träume erfüllt
eine eigene wohnung gekauft mit dem
einzigen grund sie für youtube komplette
herauszureißen und neu zu planen neu
aufzubauen und das ganze selber mit
profis durchzuführen in diesem video
geht es um eine zweimonatige suche nach
einer passenden wohnung den kredit den
kaufprozess bis hin zur
schlüsselübergabe und die erste agentur
ich wünsche euch viel spaß mit der
ersten folge von wie auch immer dieses
format heißen mag von bude zu traum um
[Musik]
völlig surreal ich bin mega dankbar dass
ich so was jetzt als youtube projekt
umsetzen darf ich bin mega pump und wir
gemerkt habe wir brauchen einen
gebürtigen namen also alles was ihren
vorschlägen hat es gerne in die
kommentare
gerne irgendwas mit bezug zu never too
small weil das mit ausschlaggebend dafür
war dass sich dieses projekt umsetzen
und deswegen erstmal zu idee wie ist das
eigentlich alles entstanden wie schon
gesagt ich habe immer unheimlich gerne
die videos von navy cis moll geguckt ein
englischsprachiger kanal der sich darum
kümmert aus alten bestehenden wohnungen
neue frische luxus apartments zu machen
die einfach gut durchdacht sind ganz
besonders eine wohnung ein projekt das
auf dem kanal gefüttert wurde habe ich
im stream mit leuten geguckt und da ist
so die erste idee entstanden es ist
abend werden was 14 16 dem
system partner es gibt so viele 70er
jahre bauten in den städten in dem er zu
wenig platz ist warum nicht so ne
wohnung nehmen sie energieeffizienter
machen besser ausstatten und einfach
mehr lebensqualität in dem raum schaffen
der schon für eine wohnung geblockt ist
also einfach mehr aus dem zeug machen
was schon da ist außerdem hat man dem
büro umbau und dort selber hand
anzulegen so viel spaß gemacht dass ich
jetzt gerne noch mehr auch abseits des
trockenbau selber machen würde also den
ersten einblick in sanitär den ersten
einblick in boden verlegen den ersten
einblick in electric all das soll in
diesem video passieren und ich möchte es
einfach selber lernen wie zur hölle
findet man oder wie habe ich eigentlich
diese passende immobilie jetzt gefunden
erstmal habe ich mir so ziemlich jede
wohnung angeschaut ohne irgendeinen plan
zu haben größe jede lage alle preise ich
habe einfach alles angeschaut und dann
irgendwann gemerkt vielleicht sollte ich
mich auf genau eine art fokussieren eine
große wohnung ist vielleicht zum start
nicht besonders schlau weil es einfach
riesengroß ist großes finanzielles
risiko viel aufwand die zu renovieren
also war die entscheidung gefallen ich
brauche eine möglichst kleine wohnung in
der stadt ist es eigentlich zu teuer
quasi unbezahlbar so weit außerhalb kann
es aber auch nicht sein weil ich will ja
selber aktiv daran arbeiten und ich kann
es mir nicht erlauben jeden tag
anderthalb stunden zur wohnung hin
fahren zu müssen um dann irgendwas
umzubauen also irgendwie so im halbe
stunden umkreis um köln und ok jetzt
wusste ich welche parameter die wohnung
haben soll wie groß sie sein soll wo sie
ungefähr sein sollen was sich potenziell
bereit bin zu zahlen aber ich hatte ja
immer noch keine ahnung und ich habe das
einzig richtige getan und jemanden
gesucht der mehr ahnung hat als ich um
alles klappt schicken zu können jemanden
zu haben der mir einfach allgemein bei
dem projekt ist ja und wenn ihr selber
rein starten wollt es gibt unheimlich
gute youtube kanäle die sich auch
komplett durch gesucht habe um
beispielsweise im occasion guckt da rein
ich werde jetzt hier nicht bei jedem
thema ins detail gehen ich probiere das
so grob zu umreißen und wer wirklich die
bleiben will der ist bei dem ok schon
deutlich besser aufgehoben als bei mir
im prinzip habe ich dann einfach bei
allen kölner maklern kölner umkreis
maklern mal auf die website guckt ob
irgendwas da ist und ein paar die mir
sympathisch ihn angerufen und gesagt hey
ich wäre potenziell an einer wohnung
interessiert die gegen den dänen und
sehnen parameter hat wenn sie was haben
melden sie sich gerne bei mir das hat
rein gar nichts gebracht diese ganzen
großen makler hat natürlich
bestandskunden die kümmern sich als
erstes um ihre bestandskunden die sie
schließen wollen wenn eine gute wohnung
rein kommt die bezahlbar ist dann geht
die erst an die leute die eh schon viel
bei denen gekauft haben und da bin ich
also nicht besonders fündig geworden
andere optionen werden natürlich noch so
sachen wie eine zwangsversteigerung
davon habe ich jetzt vorerst abgesehen
erstens war in köln in den letzten
monaten nichts besonders gutes dabei
zweitens sich als erster immobilienkauf
oder halte ich nicht für besonders
schlau die katze im sack zu kaufen
drittens habe ich mich damit einfach
unwohl gefühlt und wollte lieber die
wohnung komplett schauen können als
jetzt so ein halb dem bild zu machen mit
in der zwangsversteigerung zu gehen weil
ich einfach zu wenig ahnung habe aber
tatsächlich habe ich die wohnung im
endeffekt über moskaus gekommen und ja
vermutlich gehe sie alarmglocken bei
allen leuten an die schon irgendwie
erfahrungen damit haben und sagt
eigentlich wenn eine immobilie bei
moskau gelistet wird dann ist sie
potenziell entweder zu teuer oder
irgendwas stimmt nicht weil wenn alles
stimmen würde dann hätte sie vermutlich
ein bestandskunde schon vorher quasi
gekauft bevor sie richtig auf den
öffentlichen markt gekommen ist im
endeffekt habe ich aber dort meine
wohnung gefunden und bin ziemlich
zufrieden ich habe zu viel gezahlt warum
das aber trotzdem sinn macht und so
werde ich irgendwann in einem anderen
video erzählen im prinzip habe ich
einfach wochen lang gebrannt ich habe
mir besucher eingestellt also dass
benachrichtigt werden wenn neue
immobilien bei moskau eingestellt werden
und einfach besucht und gewartet bis
irgendwas kommt bestenfalls kommen dann
irgendwann einfach immobilien rein die
zu einem passen so war es auch bei uns
dann kann man den leuten einfach
schreiben würden denn die wunden
anschauen das haben wir auch gemacht wir
haben uns viele wohnungen angeschaut und
in den meisten fällen waren die
wohnungen belebt deswegen kann ich euch
jetzt keine ausschnitte von den
besichtigungen zeigen weil ich ja nicht
den privatkauf vor den leuten finden
kann eine wohnung allerdings tatsächlich
die die mir am besten gefallen hat 70er
jahre baus 25 quadratmetern nicht belebt
wir haben uns also diese wohnung
angeschaut die hat ziemlich gut gepasst
ich habe mich sehr gut mit dem makler
verstanden konnte nicht gut unterhalten
der wusste genau was sache ist konnte
uns alle fragen zur wohnung beantworten
es hat alles super clean gewirkt und ich
war ziemlich zufrieden weil das ziemlich
genau das war was ich gesucht hat um
aber das angebot nicht einfach so
anzunehmen wie er es gesagt hat habe ich
ein angebot gemacht was ungefähr acht
prozent unter dem veranschlagten preis
lag und tatsächlich wurde dem angebot
stattgegeben und sobald sich dann der
verkäufer und käufer auf einen preis
geeinigt haben kann man quasi den hörer
in die hand nehmen beim notar anrufen
und sagen hallo wir würden gerne unsere
wohnung zudem und den preis verkaufen
die haben sie alle unterlagen bitte
machen sie einen kaufvertrag fertig und
dann trifft man sich beim notar und
unterschreibt kauft eine wohnung heute
besonderer tag ich bin auf dem weg zum
notar ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt habe
aber auch wichtig weil dann wird alles
in die wege geleitet dann gehört die
wohnung war sie mir dann heißt es nur
noch bezahlen dann geht es weiter mit
finanzierungen suchen und so weiter aber
jetzt heute der erste große schritt in
die richtung dass die wohnung wirklich
mir gehört geil
[Musik]
wie bezahlt man aber jetzt so eine
wohnung wenn man nicht gerade 100 200
300 400 tausend euro bar auf der bank
liegen hat um das einfach so zu zahlen
man braucht ein kredit eine finanzierung
da auch so ziemlich das schlechteste
timing ausgesucht es gibt in den letzten
monaten sind die zinsen komplett durch
die decke gegangen das war abzusehen
auch schon seit letztem jahr das war es
schon so mäßig angekündigt und das geld
ist teurer geworden sich geld bei der
bank zu leihen ist teurer geworden die
zinsen sind hoch gegangen das ganze kann
man aber natürlich auch mit in seine
kalkulation aufnehmen und dann überlegen
macht es trotzdem sind für mich die
wohnung zu kaufen bei mir hat das denn
gemacht ich hab mich zum einen bei einem
online finanzierungsberater gemeldet
internet nennt sich das eigentlich wurde
mir das als ziemlich gutes ding
empfohlen bei mir kamen nur quatsch mit
soße rum und bin im endeffekt einfach
mit meinen unterlagen von bank zu bank
hier in köln gestoppt und habe mich
überall vorgestellt und hab gesagt hallo
ich hätte gerne geld was können sie mir
anbieten und dann wird man natürlich
komplett auseinandergenommen fach tun
was machen die sich die geschichte die
geringe oder
selbständigkeit dass
die viel geld verdient man wie viel geld
gibt man aus wohnt man zur miete wohnt
man isst man ledig und so weiter das
muss natürlich alles gecheckt werden
damit die bank ausrechnen kann wie
wahrscheinlich das ist dass man den
kredit wirklich zurückzahlen kann bei
mir war das zum glück ziemlich klein
wenn ich privat ziemlich wenig geld
ausgebe und bin so dann an meinen
allerersten kredit gekommen auch hier
alle zahlen daten fakten werden
irgendwann in dem abrechnungs video
kommen wenn ich weiß wie viel die
renovierung gekostet hat und so weiter
mache ich einmal eine komplette
abrechnung es ist soweit nach monaten
der suche nach monaten der kredit nach
warten auf grunderwerbsteuer untaten
unterschreiten und so weiter ist es
jetzt soweit 148
riskiert in diesem moment ich muss den
verwendungszweck auf
wohnung
geht in diesem moment
aus
1948 1000 von 120.000 euro gar nicht
mehr gehören das restliche geld das auch
beim konto ist passt gerade so für dich
steuern fürs letzte jahr also dieses
projekt ist auch wieder komplett aber
ich bin hätten es kann los in den
nächsten wochen bedeutet das also dass
jetzt bald schlüssel bekommen wir das
erste mal richtig in die wohnungen
können und der umbau geplant und das
komplette projekt denn auch hier mit
startet
im prinzip wartet man dann darauf die
grunderwerbssteuer zahlen zu dürfen und
dem verkäufer das geld schicken zu
dürfen das muss einmal amt mäßig
komplett geklärt werden und bei mehr als
zweieinhalb monate gedauert in denen man
quasi keine informationen bekommt wie
der aktuelle stand ist da muss man
einfach die füße stillhalten und warten
hat mega genervt aber irgendwann war das
auch geschafft und dann konnte ich mich
aber mit dem verkäufer wieder in
verbindung setzen und sagen hallo das
amt hat alle gelder bekommen sie haben
alle gelder bekommen sollen wir nicht
die schlüsselübergabe machen ja und dann
war es soweit der tag war gekommen an
dem ich die schlüssel zu meiner ersten
eigenen wohnung bekommen sollte
unheimlich aufgeregt obwohl ich wusste
dass eigentlich nichts mehr passiert bin
ich dann so wohnung gefahren und habe
mich mit den verkäufen betroffen im
prinzip checkt man noch einmal ist alles
so wie beschrieben man liest den
stromzähler ab und trägt das alles ein
übergibt dann die schlüssel
verabschiedet die verkäufer und steht
dann einfach in einer wohnung die einem
selber gehört oder zumindest in einer
wohnung von der einem 25 prozent gehören
75 prozent oder wie viele zimmer gehören
ja nach wie vor der bank aber man steht
in der wohnung die potenziell auf den
eigenen namen läuft und das war schon
etwas ganz besonderes was soll ich sagen
ich habe eine wohnung ich habe gerade
die schlüssel bekommen bin unglaublich
hätten das wohnungsprojekt kann starb
mit wir schauen uns jetzt erstmal
gemeinsam die wohnung an
merkmal das nicht an auch wenn das licht
da das hier ist das bad das muss muss
muss komplett geändert werden das ist
halt na ja wie soll ich sagen voll
funktionsfähig aber hält aus dem nichts
schätzen 70er jahren und das merkt eine
badewanne die zu kleine sparen aber
irgendwie dann auch keine richtige
dusche ist wenigstens das kommt komplett
weg hoffentlich publikum zum mitwippen
schiff dass wir perfekt die komplette
und die fließen über das waschbecken das
muss eigentlich alles gemacht werden
[Musik]
die kirche habe den grossraum los und
jetzt geht im prinzip direkt die große
entscheiden ist also bleibt diesem abend
ihr comeback um den raum insgesamt
größer zu machen bleibt die küche so im
raum stehen oder machen wenn sie
vielleicht die schräg zur wand all das
gilt es in den nächsten videos noch
völlig zu machen weil diese wohnung
komplett geplant werden muss aber
natürlich ist da auch wenn es ohne
ceranfeld ist und den ich nicht rauche
ich denke auch nicht im prinzip kommt ja
alles ganz oben sondern eigentlich auch
aus den best case werde ich dass sie
irgendwie auch fußbodenheizung eingebaut
bekommen ich habe keine ahnung was mit
heizungs leuten sprechen
großen raum ist klein war doch mein das
ist die band von der kirche die prothese
weg könnte man das team komplett auf
macht und ob ihr
haus zu durchsuchen
die reform ist ein einbauschrank das
finde ich ziemlich cool das dessert ist
unendlich tief also ich würde sagen er
ist
ja wahrscheinlich 90 oder so eigentlich
viel zu tief wenn diese wand hier
wegkommen
dann könnte man sich auch noch mal zehn
zentimeter mehr rausholen dem der
einbauschrank verkleinert wird irgendwie
so aber an sich schon sehr cool so
verstaubt zu haben
[Musik]
wie das ansonsten hier alles angerichtet
wird keine ahnung ich habe überhaupt
keinen plan die fenster müssen wir nicht
gemacht werden heizung ist unten ganz
okay anlage drin alles bestens nichts wo
man jetzt groß von der kompletten
eigentümergemeinschaft irgendwie was
erneuern müsste aber hier oben drin wie
die heizung hier oben funktionieren da
könnte man vielleicht mal hand anlegen
ich bin unheimlich kommt das ist mein
favourit youtube projekt seitdem ich mit
youtube angefangen habe ich freue mich
unheimlich darauf ich kann mich
handwerklich betätigen habe diesen
investment faktor irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr drin und ich finds unendlichkeit es
wäre natürlich auch dumm gewesen mit
einer riesen wohnung zu starten weil sie
einfach keine ahnung habt diese wohnung
hier ist 25 quadratmeter großen super
entspannt tag schön kleiner stab und ich
kann ich hier drin so ein bisschen
ausprobieren das ist zumindest der plan
es ist wirklich unglaublich in den
nächsten videos können wir endlich
anfangen die wohnung einmal komplett
perfekt zu vermessen auch diebe maßen
grundrisse sind aus den 70ern da kann
man quasi gar nichts mehr drauf erkennen
dann anfangen zu planen im prinzip soll
da wirklich alles neu gemacht werden und
das über zehn videos geplant ich bin
unendlich pump ich freue mich über jeden
vorschlag in den kommentaren wenn ich
irgend eine coole idee habt ich freue
mich über installieren wenn ihr sagt hey
ich lust sich zu supporten ich bin aus
köln oder was auch immer und ich habe
ahnung davon wie man den boden verlegt
bin ich mega happy darüber ich will das
natürlich alles selber machen und selber
lernen aber am besten mit einem profi an
die hand damit dass am ende auch was
wird lässt sich den video leichter zu
lassen den kanal und dann sehen wir uns
am sonntag schon wieder cous cous cous
vielen vielen dank dass sie so was
machen kann sehr geil